الى وجهه لا يعرف مستقرها غادر منزله هربا
من مخاطر السيول فيما ثمه من يقف حائرا
على اطلال الكارثه يبحث عن بلاد امن انه
حال عشرات الاسر اليمنيه في حي صاله الشرق
بتعز المنكوبين بسيون اجتاحت منازلهم قبل
ايام فما
سره داخل البيت كثيره جدا
وامراض
داخل البيت المهدده بالكثير من الكوارث
خاصه وهي تقع في سفح الجبل مباشره وعلى
ممر سيول تاتي من مناطق متعدده
فهي مهددات تماما
بالكارثه
وساحتاج الى عبارات للسيول وتحتاج الى
مصدات لمواد غذائيه ولا حتى ايوائيه في
المنازل هذه قابله للاستخدام بعد ان تمرت
بالمياه فحتى الابواب هنا اغلقت بالاتربه
التي جرفتها السيول لترسم الى جانب هذه
المشاهد المؤلمه حجم الكارثه على حقيقتها
بالنسبه للساكنين وللبعث ايضا على ارصفه
الشوارع
في منطقه الحرازيه للنازحين تضررت عشرات
الاسر وفي منطقه حبيل اوسط بالتحديد في
مديريه صالح عشرات الاسره الضررات وبعض
المنازل تعرضت لانهيارات جزئيه وايضا
مناطق في سائله نفحان ومناطق في بعض مناطق
المحوى في مديريه الصاله اولياء في
التحرير من الاعلى فقط ما يقارب اكثر من
15 بسطه متضررين ومعدمين يعني
والانقي بقيه الشوارع هناك
بساطه تعني بالعشرات خسائر كبيره اذا
تعرضت لها عشره الاسر في المدينه جراء
تدفق السيول الى المنازل لكن خسائر الباعه
على ارصفه الشوارع وصلت الى اكثر من خمسين
الف ريال سعودي بعد ان جربت السيول بضعتهم
كارثه يقول الباعه انها فاقمت معاناتهم مع
دخول البلد في منخفض جوي وتجاهل حكومي
للحد من حجم الكارثه هل سعيد العربيه تعز
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات